يواجه زوجان في مصر تهمه الاتجار بالبشر
بعد قيامهما بعرض طفلتهما الرضيع البالغه
من العمر يومان فقط للبيع على فيسبوك حيث
اقدم الزوجان على عرض طفلتهما الرضيع
للبيع مقابل 150 الف جنيه ايما يقارب خمسه
الاف دولار السبب هو ضيق احوال الاسره
الماديه الزوجه تعمل في تنظيف المنازل
ودخلها غير ثابت اما دخل الزوج فلا يكفيهم
كاسره مكونه من خمسه افراد فالزوج والزوجه
لديهما ثلاثه ابناء اكبرهم فتاه في
العشرين من العمر وجميعهم لم يحصلوا على
التعليم خلال التحقيقات اعترفا بفعلتهما
بسبب الظروف الماديه الصعبه التي يعانون
منها قالت الزوجه انها لم تكن تنوي
الاجابه مجددا وانها طلبت من الاطباء
اجهاض طفله الاخيره لكنهم رفضوا ذلك اوضحت
بعدم اقتناعها بفكره بيع طفلتها في بدايه
الامر لكن زوجها اقنعها بذلك الزوجان الان
ينتظران محاكمتهما التي تم الى العشرين من
الشهر الجاري هذه ليست الحادثه الاولى في
مصر ويمكن ان نقول انها منتشره في اكثر من
دوله نسمع بها بين كل فتره واخرى وهنا
يجدر السؤال كيف يمكن ان يؤدي ضيق الاحوال
الماديه بالاباء لبيع ابنائهم ممكن
للانسان سيارته او منزله او اي شيء مادي
يمتلكه لكن قطعه من دمه وروحه كيف يمكن ان
يحدث ذلك وهو يمكن ان يكون هناك قد وصلنا
الى مرحله لم يعد الخوف من القانون
وتطبيقه راضيا لمن يقومون بمثل هذه
الافعال خاصه انها تعتبر جريمه وتندرج تحت
جريمه الاتجار بالبشر وعقوبتها تصل الى
السجن لست سنوات وغرامه ماليه كبيره جميع
هذه الاسئله تدور في اذهاننا والاجابات
تختلف طبعا بين شخص اخر
[موسيقى]